symbole de cette rivière
le saumon de l'allier est aujourd'hui
protégé en 1994 l'espèce avait
pratiquement disparu
un décret interdit sa pêche sur
l'ensemble de la rivière la ville de ce
poisson migrateur qui peut atteindre une
taille de plus d'un mètre pour un poids
de 10 kg est une véritable épopée
il sort de son oeuf sur les frayères
total y est durant un à deux ans le
jeune saumon appelé tacot reste dans les
eaux rapides jusqu'à devenir un smolts
reconnaissable à sa robe argentée
il va ensuite dévalé la rivière jusqu'à
la mer puis traverser l'atlantique
direction le groenland où il grossit
pendant deux à trois ans et poussé par
un instinct encore mystérieux il revient
à sa rivière d'origine au risque de sa
vie
il remonte le courant pour se reproduire
sur le lieu de sa naissance à la fin du
siècle dernier
plusieurs dizaines de millier de saumons
de l'allier réussissait ce fabuleux
voyage un parcours aller retour
d'environ 10000 km
nostalgie d'une grande époque nous
sommes au barrage de la bageasse près de
brioude haute loire
voila voila ce contrat minimum dans cet
endroit autrefois réputé pour la pêche
au saumon
jean pierre vigier repris la can de son
grand-père pour une démonstration
il y avait une très jolie voix sont le
sommant de l'allier effet le salmo salar
il faut pas confondre avec justement du
pacifique de ce vent de l'allier c'est
un le saumon donc atlantique et qui ne
meurent pas après s'être produit il se
régénère et normalement s'il n'y avait
pas toutes les les obstacles où tous les
handicaps que l'on connaît aux courbes
ce fleuve
il pourrait remonter deux ou trois fois
il n'était pas rare de prendre des
secondes qui pesait 25 30 voire 40
livres
mon grand-père en 1922 en appréciant à
lavoûte chilhac de 33 livres à mettre
trente trois 33 cm de large et un second
qui avait dû remonter déjà faire la
navette deux ou trois fois
il ya différentes façons de le pêcher le
la manière la plus sophistiquée
évidemment c'est la pêche à la mouche
cette mouche
et bien c'est le dernier ce manque a
pris mon père il ya une douzaine
d'années
donc je garde précieusement c'est un peu
ici rocher mais elle évoque pour moi des
souvenirs merveilleux et est qui et qui
sont toujours présents dans mon esprit
c'est ici au mourre de la gardille à une
altitude moyenne de 1500 mètres environ
que l'allié commence à couler nous
sommes en lozère dans le département des
sources
l'eau ruisselle abondamment alimenté en
trois grandes rivières l'allier qui
rejoint la loire mais aussi le lot et le
tarn qui se jette dans la garonne
à 15 kilomètres de la source au dessus
de la ville de langogne l'allier
ressemble à un torrent de montagne très
poissonneux en truites fario une eau
polluée et guide de pêche et il ne
changerait de métier pour rien au monde
à la base on est pêcheur bernard et
après on en ferme etc etc d'abord mettre
les pieds dans l'eau le métier de guide
de pêche s'est faite au départ c'est
amener déjà qu'il avait pêchés dans des
bons points de pêche
suivant ce qu'il désire et vient entre
la rivière toute la largeur tel poisson
ou alors carrément faire de l'initiation
de la mise à niveau pour des débutants
il faut pas faire ça pour rouler sur
l'or non plus mais on a on a eu deux
vies qui est relativement à ce que le
pacte pour cette partie de la rivière
qui est assez rapide et pas très large
j'ai pris huit pieds 2 très légère 1 à
tito modules avec un moulinet très léger
aussi à g développement et il ne soit
qui est particulière à cette can qui est
fait exprès c'est une semaine numéro 2
qui est très légère et relativement
puissante aux lancers et qui va faire
des pauses et très doux et à ses lois
gossip alors les bouches en ce moment on
a vu qu'on ait fait juin il s'est quand
même la période des grandes éphémère et
en bouche de mecs et les rocettes je
suis pour les coûts du soir ainsi tout
alors pour les hommes ont promis s'ils
sont l'allier il ya les truites et les
ombres c'est les mouches un peu plus
particulière de ce style là c'est à dire
avec des petites tailles et qu'on
appelle orange fluo que les hommes
apprécient beaucoup et qui sommes pour
les hommes on a des bouches de plus
petite taille que par rapport à la fario
si on pressent à partir de valjevo mieux
d'avoir commencé avec un néoprène parce
que les ans un peu fraîche et ensuite je
lui ai pour permettre le porter que
c'est un autre problème
ensuite au niveau des chaussures et vos
biens voire ans minimum des semaines
feutre et le mieux c'est
laisse les feutres plus les couples ce
qui évite comme le lit est formée
essentiellement de galets ronds et les
german sur les bords recouvert de vases
en bordure évite de passer à l'autre
en compagnie de ce milan royal
nous quittons langogne pour le réservoir
de naussac un magnifique plan d'eau où
se pratiquent les plaisirs nautiques axe
migrateurs pour les poissons l'allier
l'est aussi pour les oiseaux plus de 100
espèces d'oiseaux nicheurs ont été
recensées par les ornithologues avec
quelques espèces très rares comme le
faucon pèlerin le hibou grand duc le
plus grand rapace nocturne d'europe ou
encore le circaète jean le blanc qui se
nourrit surtout de serpents nous sommes
aux portes des gorges de l'allier
là où le saumon aime se reproduire des
gorges rocheuses souvent inaccessibles
qui préserve la nature sauvage
mais avant d'accéder à cet endroit
paradisiaque
le saumon doit franchir de nombreux
obstacles de la mer aux frayères du
haut-allier des solutions ont été
apportées pour lui faciliter le voyage
barrière de sept mètres de haut
le barrage de poutès en est un exemple
le barrage de poutès depuis la début des
années 40 avec stériliser pratiquement
50% du potentiel en saumon pour l'allier
et maintenant il est aménagé depuis 1986
il est devenue perméable pour le saumon
sur la rivière pour les poissons qui
part de très haut il ya environ une
vingtaine d'obstacles à franchir plus ou
moins difficile suivant la configuration
des sites et surtout suivant le débit de
la rivière au printemps pour un un
saumon il existe ce qu'on appelle une
fenêtre physiologiques de passage en
espère d'adaptation du passage de l'eau
douce et l'eau salée et 7
ce passage se situe dans une période
bien déterminée qui n'est pas très
longue
donc il faut que les poissons arrivent à
temps en essais et l'aménagement d'un
site et d'un ouvrage tel que celui ci
dépend beaucoup de sa configuration
d'origine
au départ on voyait très bien
techniquement qu'il était possible
d'aménager un ascenseur à quoi sont pour
la montée par contre on n'était pas sûr
qu'on arrive à faire dévaler les
poissons les jeunes pour qu'ils aillent
vers la mer au niveau de la prise d'eau
alors le toboggan exister il a
simplement été réaménagé pour pouvoir
être adapté au transit par les poissons
ont les tests ont conçu ce fait à
déverser des poissons à l'amont et à
regarder avec des caméras ce qui se
passait et a aménagé pour la descente
soit compris confortable pour le poisson
est actuellement en l'an 2000
au printemps il a dévalé ici 13000
smolts au niveau de ce barrage pour le
plus grand bonheur d'un héron que la
caméra de surveillance n'a pas perturbé
mais si tout se passe bien pour la
dévalaison qu'en est il pour la remontée
du saumon à poutès les poissons prennent
l'ascenseur il faut utiliser le
comportement du poisson et le guider
vers ce dispositif a pout s le guidage
s'effectue par un débit qui transitent
par une partie aménagée en passe à
poissons qui conduit assez naturellement
vers un piège c'est à dire une menace
qui est constitué par la cub de
l'ascenseur lui-même
et quand les poissons rampe dans la
nasse ils sont piégés dans l'ascenseur
et l'ascenseur remonte ensuite suivant
une programmation déterminé ici
actuellement la source remonte toutes
les deux heures on effectue des
comptages puisque l'ascenseur nous
permet de filmer avec une caméra toutes
les remontées et de voir la taille des
poissons et combien sont passés sur ce
barrage donc fort bien de géniteurs sont
présents sur la zone amont on estime
qu'entre 300 et 500 aux noms rejoignent
actuellement les frayères dû au talent y
est
autre barrage autre méthode pour la
restauration du saumon la technique a
laissé parfois beaucoup plus radicales
comme à saint-etienne du vigan à
quelques kilomètres de poutès
grâce à la mobilisation des pêcheurs edf
en 1996 a pris la décision de détruire
ce petit barrage hydroélectrique
il y a des jours où l'on aimerait bien
se prendre pour un saumon et rejoindre
cette nature sauvage des gorges de
l'allier un endroit souvent
impénétrables que nous fait découvrir
robert faure c'est un endroit
incontournable des gorges de l'allier ça
s'est fait en trois alleyras et le
nouveau monde chapeauroux on à peu près
à mi-chemin endroits privilégiés
obligatoirement les saumons sont obligés
de passer par là sachant que c'est à peu
près 14 km il n'y a pas de route d'accès
disons à goudronner
wedge route de laillé
grande est exceptionnel
voilà
et voilà le vv tu seras
un effectif qui crée et préside un point
c'est le vairon manié verront morts
alors il ya deux choses il ya souvent
les niveaux d'eau qui nous permettent de
pêcher différemment en début de saison
les salmonidés chez nous en plein dedans
ça se pouvait dans les fosses
relativement profonde
donc on utilise ceci comme en turquie
est toute simple mais là un plombage en
tête qui est beaucoup plus lourd pour
descendre plus profondément dans la
veine d'eau et la cantonale dans les
période mai juin où le niveau d'eau est
moins important on utilise le même
principe mais avec un petit milk là
devant qui a tendance à être moins l'eau
et à pêcher dans moins de profondeur
d'eau la technique est toute simple
s'agit d'avoir une quinzaine de mètres
50 et 3 m avec un moulinet avec un
fichier de préférences montée en 16 ou
18 centièmes et la de souche mais 60 70
cm de balai en 14 centièmes ceux ci
relier avec un et brillant ça permet
aussi le principal du moulinet de ne pas
briller
il faut savoir ya pas de truites lâchées
absolument pas la rivière se régénère
d'elle même par prendre il ya un soutien
une population qui effectué pour les
bleus ce moment les mettre en grande
quantité pour qu'il ya en retour qu'ils
se fassent on va dire dans un premier
temps un an et demi deux ans portejoie
de la mer et que deux ans après puisse
remonter reproduire se noue à voilà
petit quelque chose c'est pas bon
ah voilà un petit à caen
il ya une petite différence avec la
truite on va essayer de le visualiser le
milieu de l'oeil si on tire un trait
tout droit c'est l'excroissance de la
bouche
al'inverse de la truite ya une bouche
beaucoup plus grande et on peut
considérer que ça que là c'est pas
évident en forme avait un peu plus
conséquent que la truffe et puis dans
ces tâches sont caractéristiques aussi
de petits poissons de toutes façons les
poissons doit être obligatoirement remis
à l'eau ça c'est un poisson qui va se
fortifie l'année prochaine très
certainement et qui va dévaler en 2001
ces gorges de l'allier on peut les
diviser en deux grandes parties une
première partie de langogne à prades
ça c'est une partie très sauvage très
inquiet fait 13 inaccessible seule
possibilité d'accès c'est soit le train
il ya réussi à travers de multiples
tunnels et viaducs allonger cette
rivière soit alors
sport devine mais d'un très haut niveau
et ça c'est le domaine du pêcheur
sportif à un pêcheur on va dire un peu
d' aventure c'est une partie vraiment
très sauvage alors qu'à partir de prades
et bien là c'est accessible à de la
balade en famille en canoë kayak
il suffit d'une petite leçon au départ
et on peut aller se promener comme sur
n'importe quel rivières de france calme
et tranquille les autres basaltiques
sont derrière nous on est environ à 30
km du puy et entre le puy et les gorges
de l'allier ici il ya ce que l'on
appelle les plateau du devès du volet
volcaniques
environ 200 volcans qui lorsqu'ils ont
exposé il ya entre 600 mille et deux et
trois millions d'années environ en
provoquer ces coulées de lave qui sont
mieux mourir ici dans les gorges de
l'allier la maintenant en aval de prades
et jusqu à brioude
on va voir des petits villages qui sont
la plupart du temps bâti sur des coulées
volcaniques très riche en arômes ans
avec de petites chapelles des petites
églises dont but en vienne xiième siècle
et beaucoup de peintures murales à
l'intérieur la chapelle de sainte marie
des choses c'est l'emblème des gorges de
l'allier
le village féodal de chillac construit
sur une falaise d'orgues basaltiques
accueil à musée de paléontologie qui
rassemble de nombreux fossiles
découverts près des rives de l'allier
rhinocéros éléphants gazelle yens ours
tigre vivaient ici il y a deux millions
d'années mais c'est un autre genre de
petites bêtes qui intéresse aujourd'hui
jean pierre vigier jo pêche à la petite
bête la plus bête que nous pouvons tous
les pierres et qui est très très
présente dans chaque quête de courant
simplement écrire il essaie de retourner
la terre et voilà il y en a
quelques-unes ici voyez y en a
quelques-unes ici qu'ils se sauvent la
voilà c'est des petites bêtes dont les
truites et surtout les hommes font très
friande
mais continuons notre descente de la
rivière avec un retour à brioude qui
marque la fin du rottal y est avant de
rejoindre leurs zones de frayères les
saumons deviennent tous ici franchissant
l'obstacle par une passe à poissons très
bien aménagé et bien accueillante
à travers ce joli soit 7 face à poissons
jouent un rôle déterminant dans les
efforts de réimplantation du saumon pour
que se perpétue au mieux les qualités de
la souche du saumon de l'allier
c'est là que les techniciens du conseil
supérieur de la pêche viennent capturer
quelques beaux géniteur leur laitance
sert à féconder les oeufs des femelles
élevées en captivité et ainsi produire
des alevins qui sort est un produit dans
la rivière
aujourd'hui didier bouquet actionne le
dispositif de fermeture du bassin ce qui
nous permet de découvrir la richesse
halieutique de la libye pour l'instant
on voit pas grand chose à les poissons
sont plus dans la zone profonde
donc il faut attendre un peu
c'est l'envié qui viennent de remonter
au sol à l'arrière
voilà elle se voit bien la belle truite
vos poissons l'allier on se retrouve
exactement dans la zone où la rivière
passe du jeune de vale gorge un petit
peu accentués profonde à une zone de
plaine on se trouve vraiment une limite
au niveau des répartitions d'espèces et
c'est vrai que à brioude sur ce site on
arrive à retrouver jusqu'à 26 27 espèces
différentes de poissons ce qui est quand
même une particularité très intéressant
d'une diversité et donc d'une rivière de
bonne santé et de bonne qualité
présent dans la passe à poissons la
perche aller retour mais voir de barbour
de poisson quand même de bonne taille
on a beau chevesnes espèce très commune
et il est en parfait état et très beau
poisson ou bien vous dire qu'ici en
règle générale c'est le gros saumons
qu'on cherche à capturer donc c'est plus
facile car on a un gros poisson
apprendre que les petits poissons dans
les programmes de restauration du saumon
il a fallu effectivement capturé les
gros géniteur pour toujours avoir une
descendance de souche alliés et 7 passes
à poissons permet régulièrement
généralement l'automne sur la deuxième
petite migration des saumons moment où
ils vont sur l'or vraiment sur leurs
zones de frayères permet ne capturer les
géniteurs jusqu'avant la reproduction
puisqu'on va aller capturer au mois
d'octobre sur des coups d'eau
au coup de sifflet du chef de gare dans
leur sac gonflés à l'hélium l'état trop
empruntent le train de la ligne nîmes
clermont ferrand pour aider au retour du
saumon ces alevins issus de la souche
alliés sont déposés sur les frayères où
il aurait dû naître après le train ils
descente en raft jusqu'aux lieux
inaccessibles des gorges du rotalier
souhaitons leur bonne chance pour la
grande aventure qu'il revienne
suffisamment nombreux pour faire encore
un jour le bonheur des pêcheurs